and i also have
uh another one that you didn't mention
that's that's that's
uh one of my favorite ones is uh so
you probably heard of this it's uh i
think it's called
deep rembrandt it's the project where
they they
trained i think there was a
collaboration between
the uh sort of the experts in in
rembrandt uh
painting in netherlands and a group an
artificial intelligence group
where they train an algorithm to
replicate the style
of the rembrandt and they actually
printed a
a portrait that never existed before uh
in the style of rembrandt they they uh i
think they
printed it only on a sort of uh on the
canvas that
you know using pretty much same types of
paints and stuff
and to me it was mind-blowing yeah it's
in the space of art that's interesting
there hasn't been um
maybe that's that's it but i i think
there hasn't been an image in that
moment yet in the space of art
you haven't been able to achieve
superhuman level performance in the
space of art
even though there was you know there's
this big famous thing where
there was a piece of art was purchased i
guess for a lot of money yes
yeah but it's still you know people are
like in the space of music at least um
that's you know it's clear that human
created pieces
are much more popular so there hasn't
been a moment where it's like
oh this is we're now i would say in the
space of
music what makes a lot of money we're
talking about serious money
it's music and movies or like shows and
so on
and entertainment there hasn't been a
moment where
ai created uh ai was able to create
a piece of music or a piece of
uh cinema like netflix show
that is uh you know that's sufficiently
popular to make
a ton of money yeah and that moment
would be very very powerful
because that's like a that's in the ai
system being used to make a lot of money
and like direct of course ai tools
like even premiere audio editing all the
editing everything i do
to edit this podcast there's a lot of ai
involved i won't actually this is
a program i want to talk to those folks
just because i want to nerd out it's
called
izotope i don't know if you're familiar
with it they have a bunch of tools of
audio processing
and they have i think they're boston
based just
it's so exciting to me to use it like on
the audio here
because it's all machine learning it's
not
because most most audio production stuff
is like any kind of processing you do is
very basic signal processing
and you're tuning knobs and so on they
have all of that of course
but they also have all of this machine
learning stuff like where you actually
give it training data you select parts
of the audio you train on you
you train on it and it it figures stuff
out
it's it's great it's able to detect uh
like
the ability of it to be able to separate
voice and music for example or voice in
anything
is incredible like it it just
it's clearly exceptionally good at uh
you know applying these different neural
networks models to
to just separate the different kinds of
signals from the audio
that that uh okay so that's really
exciting
photoshop adobe people also use it but
to generate
a piece of music yeah that will sell
millions
a piece of art yeah yeah no i agree and
you know it's uh
that's that's you know uh you know
i as i mentioned i offer my my ai class
and you know
an integral part of this is the project
right so it's it's
my favorite ultimate favorite part
because it typically
we have these you know project
presentations the last
two weeks of the classes right before
you know the the christmas break and
it's it's
sort of it adds this cool excitement
and every time i'm i'm amazed you know
with with some
uh some projects that people uh
you know come up with and so uh and
quite a few of them are actually you
know they some
have some link to uh to to arts i mean
you know i think
last year uh we had a group
who designed an ai uh producing uh
hocus japanese poems oh wow
uh so and some of them so you know it
got
trained on the on the english space
hikers hikers right there
so um and and some of them you know
they get to present like the the top
selection they were pretty good
i mean you know i mean of course i'm not
i'm not the specialist but yeah
you you read them and you see it seems
profound
yes yeah it seems so it's kind of cool
we also had a couple of projects where
people tried to to
teach ai how to play like rock music
classical music uh i think and
and and popular music
interestingly enough uh you know
classical music was
among the most difficult ones and and
and you know of course if you
if you know uh you know if if you look
at the you know the
uh like grand masters of music like
bach right so there is a lot of uh there
is a lot of
almost math yeah well he's very
mathematical exactly
so so this is i would imagine that at
least some style
of this music could be picked up but
then you have those
completely different spectrum of of you
know classical composers
and so you know it and you know
it's almost like you know you don't have
to sort of look at the data
you just listen to it and say nah that's
that's that's not it not yet that's not
right yeah
that's how i feel too this open ai has i
think open muse or something like that
the system
it's cool but it's like yeah it's not
compelling for some
for some reason it could be a
psychological reason too
maybe we need to have a human being
a tortured soul behind the music i don't
know
yeah no that absolutely i completely
agree
but yeah whether or not we'll have at
one day we'll have
you know a song written by an ai
engine to to be in like in top
charts yeah musical charts i wouldn't be
surprised
i wouldn't be surprised i wonder if we
already have one
and it just hasn't been announced
we wouldn't know
you